en france fin janvier le drian sera
auditionné cet après midi par le sénat
au sujet de la crise des sous marins
entre paris et ses alliés après le pdg
de naval groupies hier c'est donc au
tour du ministre des affaires étrangères
de s'expliquer sur les conséquences de
l'annulation par l'australie du contrat
du siècle profit des etats-unis et du
royaume-uni ont fait le point avec notre
reporter nadège à dera sach la première
partie de l'audition de jean yves le
drian ministre des affaires étrangères
est prévue à 18h30 auditions et qui
devrait être diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du sénat alors le sénat a
dominé par l'opposition de droite n'a
pas fermé la porte à la création d'une
commission d' enquête sur ce dossier
commission réclamée par le groupe
socialiste et la députée centriste
nathalie goulet mais avant la création
d'une éventuelle commission denquête une
série d'auditions va être conduite c'est
aussi ce qu'on privilégie à l'assemblée
nationale alors l'annoncent le 15
septembre dernier d'un partenariat
stratégique entre l'australie le
royaume-uni et les etats-unis s'est donc
soldé par l'annulation du contrat du
siècle conclu entre l'australie et la
france pour la construction de 12 sous
marins français pour un montant de 34
milliards d'euros alors cette annulation
a provoqué une crise diplomatique sans
précédent entre les etats-unis et la
france la france a même d'ailleurs
quelques jours plus tard rappelé son
ambassadeur de washington
mais depuis les choses semblent s'être
apaisées en puisque joe baydan emmanuel
macron se sont entretenus la semaine
dernière les deux hommes ont convenu de
procéder à la mise en place de
consultations approfondies pour
restaurer la confiance entre les deux
oui mais c'est une affaire qui malgré
les apparences pourrait laisser quelques
traces